there are a few rules in life you must
abide by if you want to get through it
unharmed one of witches do not
plagiarize the work of scar from The
Lion King golden rule number one the
words so the word Stars Bradley Cooper
and he's a writer he doesn't do it
professionally he wants to do it
professionally but he's just not good
enough to do it professionally you know
he's just like oh that's my hobby and I
want to make money at it because that's
what I love and I just can't do it like
one of those sad sacks you see on
American Idol were you like no then he
comes across this book and transcript
form it's obviously been shelved for
years and he's like uh it's great I'll
just pass it off his mind then it gets
really big and Jeremy Irons is like hey
douche that was mine and you're like
awesome this is a sweet premise let's do
it and it started out as a really sweet
premise for one third of this movie I
was like this is cool it's cool and that
really slow drama kind of way cool
that's the kind of drama I can roll with
you know it's an interesting premise you
can see it building you're like oh man
this is totally gonna fall apart for
this poor bastard Zoe Saldana it's hot
you know that's not bad but enough of
the hot chicks this is all about the
upper class doctors of writing yeah and
hot chicks but you feel for Bradley
Cooper you know he's just struggling he
wants to make his hobby his career he
just wants to get paid he wants to be
one of the greats and you're like oh man
I wish you could be and then when he
actually goes forward he's like he's
passing this work off as his own you
kind of feel for him I mean I'd like to
think in that situation I wouldn't do it
but you do see his situation you're like
I don't think you're a dick for doing it
if it were my work I think you're a
piece of [ __ ] but yeah you know there's
a lot of pressure on the guy when he has
to sit down with Jeremy Irons you're
like oh this is what I've been waiting
for do it and it's really cool for a few
minutes and then it gets boring Jeremy
Irons is telling his backstory and
you're thinking okay it's gonna take
like two minutes to do only think it
doesn't it takes like 30 minutes it
seems like 30 minutes anyway it's like
30 minutes of Jeremy Irons telling his
backstory they're getting all the
visuals like it's a movie in scenes but
Jeremy Irons is doing the voice-over
it's like he's reading the book of his
life so you're like [ __ ] I feel like I'm
in fourth grade story time you know
where you're like oh I could listen to
this or I could just sleep now not that
a back story is a bad thing and even the
format fit for the movie but I mean it
doesn't have
to be a half an hour long maybe just a
couple minutes make it a FEMA give me
the highlights I felt like I was on a
bench with an old guy who was telling me
his story and I just wanted to be like
can you speed this up please in the
movie he already immediately feel for
Jeremy Irons because his work was stolen
you don't need the whole backstory you
know the highlights would be fine you
already have a conflict in your mind
where you're like I understand Bradley
Cooper's dilemma but yeah Jeremy Irons
is in the right he should kick his ass
why they felt they needed 30 minutes of
backstory to tell me that that I don't
know now Bradley Cooper this guy he's
getting work rightfully so that dudes a
good actor I loved him in comedies like
The Hangover but he shows that he can do
the drama thing yeah thing I'm doing a
movie about a book and literacy and I
said things I couldn't think of anything
good whatever the people in this movie
are great but I thought there was gonna
be more conflict in this movie you know
I mean there's no real conflict Jeremy
Irons goes to Bradley Cooper and he's
like hey you ripped off my work alright
peace I feel like with all the time they
took to tell Jeremy Irons back story
that could have taken that time
allocated it to show more of the
conflict between Bradley Cooper and
Jeremy Irons more of Bradley Cooper's
inner conflict cuz he knows he did
something bad you know that would have
made the movie a lot better in the end
the first third of the movie was great
and then you know Jeremy Irons is
telling his story and you're like
alright speed it up then the movie just
kind of gets jumbled and ends I've never
loved this set up in one third of a
movie so much and then had the rest of
the movie just fall so flat for me it
pains me and it's sad to say that the
words is alright but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus a couple days yep
already forgot alright so who's your
favorite author out there we're gonna
jump track to book some of you're gonna
be like whoa whoa whoa what's this non
movie question but that's what I'm
curious about your favorite author who
is he or she comment below let me know I
promote literacy yeah and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]